much of Pakistan has been plunged Into
Darkness the country's energy Minister
says the national power grid went down
early Monday morning causing a
widespread breakdown in the power system
nearly 220 million people are without
electricity authorities say efforts to
restore the system are underway but that
could still take several hours let's go
live to our correspondent in Islamabad
Kamal Haider Kamal what's the latest any
progress made to restore power
well the authorities particularly the
ministry for power and the minister is
saying that they are trying to solve
this problem that it will take maybe up
to 12 hours before this is sorted out
they're blaming a fluctuation in the
frequency which led to the shutdown of
the great stations and also disrupted
and tripped a several power lines major
power lines heading to baluchistan
Province as well as to the city of
Karachi this is not of course the first
time that this has happened this is the
second time since the new Minister for
power took over he had said that there
will be an investigation and when this
happened last time people of course
across Pakistan are worried as to
whether the minister is even competent
enough to deal with this crisis however
if this is prolonged it could lead to a
chain reaction and that of course could
mean disruption and power supply water
supply sorry to major cities the
concerned department is saying that they
are confident that the power will be
restored 117 great stations like the one
you see behind me power has been
suspended to them here in Islamabad
alone major cities across Pakistan are
facing the outage and of course there is
also the ministry saying that they're
trying to restore and have partially
restored power to critical
infrastructure such as airports and
other key in installations Kamal what
does this mean for a country that's
already dealing with so many uh
challenges and economic crisis and
energy crisis as well
well indeed it is a huge concern because
as you mentioned the challenges are
multiple there is a foreign exchange a
shortage within the country that means
the banks are not able to open LCS
thousands of containers are stuck at the
Karachi Port uh this raising power
Tariff of course has also affected the
industry because they've been suffering
several hours of power outages even
before this particular major breakdown
so many Industries have shut down uh
there is of course going to be a
knock-on effect on fuel prices because
the country now wants to go back to that
IMF bailout package talks with the IMF
stalled when the government was not able
to meet the strict conditionalities of
the IMF so all kinds of troubles and
this particular one if it prolongs I
would of course also mean loss of time
and money when it comes to Industrial
output Lord and of course affecting
everybody's daily lives thank you very
much for that Kamal Haider is our
correspondent in Islamabad Pakistan